allons plus loin continue avec notre
grand débat on va s'arrêter sur un texte
qui vient des députés de la majorité et
qui remet l ivg au coeur des
préoccupations c'est le délai légal qui
pose question et notamment depuis le
confinement pour certaines femmes les 12
semaines on était trop juste au
printemps dernier lorsque tout s'est
arrêté
et elle serait de toute façon trop juste
de manière générale oui mais attention
certains médecins et élus de droite
alerte avorté après 12 semaines cause
selon eux des questions d'ordre éthique
ou d'ordre sanitaire on va ouvrir le
débat avec nos invités dans un instant
d'abord les détails du texte c'est avec
marion delpech allongée de douze à
quatorze semaines le délai légal d'accès
ali vg c'est la principale proposition
du texte de loi visant à renforcer le
droit à l'avortement
selon un récent rapport de l'assemblée
nationale 5000 femmes sont contraintes
de se rendre chaque année dans des pays
proches ou le délai légal est supérieure
à la france pour pratiquer une ivg
la plupart sont en situation de
vulnérabilité
pénalisé par des inégalités
territoriales ou des retards de prise en
charge comme l'expliquent la directrice
du planning familial
aujourd'hui la seule possibilité qu'on
d'assez ou à vivre une grossesse qui ne
souhaitent pas ou alors elles sont
obligées de partir à l'étranger
il faut juste savoir que ça coûte entre
800 et 3000 euros
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya celles qui
ont les moyens et certains n'ont pas les
moyens
ça fait penser à un peu vous savez avant
la loi sur l'avortement des femmes qui
avait les moyens d'aller en angleterre
épisode qui nous pouvait boy qui vivait
une grossesse ce qu'elle ne souhaitait
pas donc c'est sa fin des quarts entre
les femmes on n'est pas toutes égales du
coup et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
intolérable aujourd'hui outre
l'extension du délai d' ivg le texte
prévoit d'étendre la compétence des
sages-femmes pour réaliser des ivg
chirurgicales jusqu'à la dixième semaine
de grossesse
une autre proposition vise à supprimer
la double clause de conscience
spécifique al ivg une concession faite
par simone veil en 1975 pour faire
passer la loi mais décriée aujourd'hui
par les défenseurs des droits des femmes
qui la considèrent stigmatisante
enfin le texte propose de rendre
obligatoire la pratique du tiers payant
pour unis
j'ai de garantir dans tous les cas sa
confidentialité et de supprimer le délai
de réflexion de deux jours pour
confirmer sa demande
porté par la députée eds albane gaillot
la proposition de loi a obtenu un large
soutien de la république en marche et de
l'ensemble de la gauche au sénat à
majorité de droite
le texte sera vraisemblablement rejeter
mais pour la sénatrice et ancienne
ministre des droits des femmes laurence
rossignol
son examen en première lecture permettra
aux textes de poursuivre son chemin
parlementaire
et justement laurence rossignol est avec
nos bons soirs oz sénatrice ps de l'oise
vice-présidente du sénat membre de la
commission des affaires sociales ancien
ministre d famille de l'enfance et des
droits des femmes avec nous également
daniel hassoun bienvenus j'en ai
gynécologue obstétricienne vous avez
dirigé le centre dit vg de l'hôpital
delafontaine à saint-denis
vous avez fait partie de l'équipe de
recherche de l'anc est fécond sur les
pratiques contraceptives en france et
vous travaillez auprès des ong pour
former aux nouvelles technologies dans
les domaines de la santé reproductive
avec nos également mais à distance
israël nisand bonsoir vous êtes
professeur de gynécologie obstétrique à
l'université de strasbourg spécialiste
en procréation médicalement assistée
président du collège national des
gynécologues et obstétriciens français
et fondateur du forum européen de
bioéthique enfin avec nous également
corinne imbert bonsoir vous êtes
sénatrice de la charente-maritime
rattaché au groupe et l'air vous êtes
secrétaire du sénat membre de la
commission des affaires sociales les
membres de la mission d'évaluation et de
contrôle de la sécurité sociale merci à
tous les quatre corinne imbert justement
on viens de l'entendre dans le sujet de
marion la majorité au sénat a été très
clair et ne veut pas rallonger ce délai
de douze à quatorze semaines pour une
ivg lecomte même déposé une motion
préalable et rejeter le texte avant même
la discussion des articles pourquoi ce
point de vue si tranchée quels sont vos
arguments
les arguments ce sa porte sur les trois
points essentiels delà du texte à savoir
que un rallongement de 12 semaines à 14
semaines de grossesse égard
semaines d'aménorrhée cette semaine sans
mail il faut savoir que 95% des
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
intervienne avant la 10e semaine ça
s'éteint c'est un premier point est un
point important au cours de la 14e
semaine et bien également évidemment le
foetus est développé et on voit
apparaître les premiers signes de des
organes sexuels qui qui se forment et
donc on considère que en fait c'est pas
tant un problème d'accès ivg pour lequel
je considère qu effectivement c'est une
urgence et qu'il faudrait qu'on puisse
répondre aux femmes qui viennent
consulter pour une interruption
volontaire de grossesse parce que c'est
j'imagine jamais un plaisir d'aller
demander une interruption volontaire de
grossesse qu'on puisse apporter une
réponse dans un délai d'une semaine ce
qui me paraîtrait un délai raisonnable
pour répondre à la demande de la femme
autre point du du texte la clause de
conscience la double cause de conscience
pour les médecins qui effectivement été
un élément d'équilibré de la loi zerg et
qui aujourd'hui force est constater que
ce n'est pas un frein pour l'accès à
l'ulg et je vais faire le lien avec la
première
le premier point de ce texte de loi je
pense que si on allonge le délai pour
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
à 14 semaines qu'on aura peut-être un
peu plus de médecins qui feront valoir
cette double clause de conscience
enfin un troisième point de 2,7 de ce
texte permettre étendre la compétence
des sages femmes pour leur permettre
de pratiquer l'interruption volontaire
de process instrumentale or ceci est
permis par une expérimentation qui a été
votée dans le code cadre de la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale donc une
expérimentation qui est proposée sur
trois ans donc elle est juste démarré et
il me paraissait prématuré d'inscrire
cette possibilité dans la loi alors
avant même que l'expérimentation de
trois ans puisse se dérouler si vous
permettez je voudrais qu'on se concentre
vraiment dans ce débat sur l'un des
articles de ce texte laurence rossignol
ce passage de délai de 12 à 14 semaines
de grossesse on entend des arguments de
la droite sénatoriale d'ordre médical
d'ordre philosophique aussi un peu
d'ordre éthique est ce que vous répondez
écoutez moi je ne suis pas médecin je
vais laisser les médecins qui sont dans
ce débat répondre sur les arguments
d'ordre médical
ce que je sais simplement c'est que
environ 2000 femmes par an vont avorter
à l'étranger parce qu'elles ont dépassé
le délai légal en france qu' elle paye
elle-même lors ivg alors que s'il avait
été pratiquée en france il prend en
charge par la sécurité sociale que un
certain nombre de femmes découvrent
tardivement leur grossesse pour des
raisons diverses
il faut avoir en tête un chiffre c'est
que 75 % des ivg sont pratiquées sur des
femmes sous contraception
on peut discuter de la lecture et de la
qualité de leur contraception mais
néanmoins il ya des femmes qui sous
contraception ne comprennent pas
qu'elles sont enceintes et le découvre
tardivement il ya les très jeunes filles
qui elles ne savent même pas ce qui leur
arrive parce qu'elles connaissent ni le
record ni l'analyse des événements
nouveaux qui se passe dans leur corps et
les éventuels déni de grossesse via des
éventuels déni de grossesse enfin bref
c'est très marginal
donc je ne sais très marginal c'est pour
ça que je me disais corinne imbert à
l'instant la majorité des l'immense
majorité des femmes recourent rapidement
alors ivg quand elles le peuvent
et puis j'en dirai un mot tout à l'heure
il ya quand même des dysfonctionnements
dans l'offre de soins dans l'axé a dit
vg nous avons fermé nous la france 22%
des centres dirigés au cours des 15
dernières années
quand nous débattons avec les ministres
de la santé successifs de la
réorganisation de la carte hospitalière
quand on ferme des hôpitaux de prod2
province et bien quand on faire une
m'étonne quand on ferme une maternité le
plus souvent on ferme aussi un centre
d'orthogénie avec et on éloigne l'accès
à diverger quand il ya un an je
demandais à madame busin lorsqu'elle a
mis en place les hôpitaux de proximité
que dans le cahier des charges de ces
hôpitaux de proximité il y un centre
d'orthogénie elle a refusé
donc on a des dd considérant qu'ils sont
spécifiques à chaque femme parce que
chaque femme est différente et chaque
fois là des considérants qui sont liées
aux défaillances de l'offre de soin
ensemble en france est une formidable
hypocrisie parce qu'en fin de compte ça
nous arrange bien que nos voisins face
ce que nous on ne veut pas faire et on
compte sur l'espagne les pays bas ou la
grande bretagne pour suppléer à nos
états d'âme
abordant le volet médical si vous le
voulez bien et israël nisand pratiquer
un avortement après 12 semaines
ce n'est pas la même chose qui après 14
semaines
on entendait corinne imbert parler de
2,2 des organes génitaux qui
commençaient à se former est ce que
c'est vrai que cela pose un problème
c'est différent pour les médecins avant
de vous répondre je voudrais dire que ça
fait trente ans que je n'ai pas envoyé
en hollande
une patiente même au delà de 14 semaines
même au delà de 16 semaines parce que
nous avons dans la loi de la france qui
est excellente
une solution qui s'appelle liège et pour
cause psycho social qui nous permet de
prendre en charge bien mieux qu'une ivg
une femme qui est un déni de grossesse
une jeune femme qui se trouve n'avoir
pas été capable de se savoir enceinte et
donc jamais et j'ai toujours interdite
dans mon service voix ont fait 2000 200
ivg par an donc 1 % des ivg de france
j'ai interdit qu'on envoie les femmes en
hollande pour faire des gestes que nous
pouvons faire en france et ceci
gratuitement
maintenant pour vous répondre la
littérature internationale parce qu'il
ya pas de littérature française sur le
sujet ou très peu malheureusement n'a
pas fait de recherches sur le sujet dit
que de toute façon plus on fait lit vg
et tactiquement
plus il y à des risques et plus elle est
difficile à réaliser
et donc je ci est très clair plus on
alors il n'y a pas de problème éthique
les médecins qui accompagne les femmes
et le collège que j'ai présidée jusqu'à
la semaine dernière comporte énormément
de messages qu'ils veulent
sapphire totalement dans le sens du
choix aux femmes
ces médecins me disent à 70% d'entre eux
attention au delà du délai actuel on va
pas faire et donc ça va nous poser un
problème vous évoquiez la filière
d'orthogénie très fragilisé par des
décisions successives de la droite et de
la gauche qui ont détérioré le tiche
hospitalier bien moi je dis veux-t-on
améliorer la situation des femmes qui
demandent une ivg
oui parce qu ils pas en avant en
allongeant le délai qui en donnant des
moyens au centre d'orthogénie et des
moyens considérables et ont les fléchant
pour qu'une femme soit prise en urgence
chaque fois qu'elle demande une ivg je
n'ai jamais vu de femme de demander une
ivg tardives par contre des femmes qui
demandent à ce qu'on les prenne tout de
suite y en a tout plein et dans les
services qui sont sursaturé avec des
personnels insuffisant on leur donne un
rendez-vous à quatre semaines en leur
disant rassure toi comme on a allongé le
délai on vas pouvoir te faire une ivg
plus tardive et bien moi qui suis un
vrai défenseur des femmes
pas de communication mais de chanter des
femmes je vous dis c'est pas la première
chose à faire d'allonger le délai de
réponse
je crois d'abord je voudrais répondre
sur une première chose c'est dire que on
va régler le problème des termes plus
tardif en réglant le problème de l'accès
aux soins certainement pas certes
évidemment que nous sommes favorables à
augmenter l'accessibilité des femmes
l'ouverture des centres dits vg bien sûr
nous sommes éminemment favorable et nous
savons très bien qu'il y a dans
certaines régions des dysfonctionnements
évidents
non seulement pour recevoir les femmes
et même pour leur proposer les
différentes méthodes qui existent
mais nous aurons toujours des femmes qui
seront au delà du délai et pour lequel
ce n'est pas l'histoire d'avoir refusé
une ivg qui est en cause c'est le fait
qu'elle arrive pour toute une série de
circonstances madame rossignol les a
effectivement énumérés et qu'il fait que
effectivement il faut réécrire la loi
ouvre cette minorité de femmes elles
viennent pas 14 semaines et on les fait
pas traîner
elles sont déjà à 15 semaines sont déjà
cessé le deuxième argument de deux
d'israël nisand qui consiste à dire ces
femmes là il faut les prendre dans le
cas de l'interruption médicale de
grossesse img l'ihem gély mg est réservé
depuis la loi veil à des femmes dont la
grossesse met en jeu leur santé ou
lorsqu il y a une malformation chez
l'enfant à naître
certes c'est une possibilité mais
pourquoi faire passer par une procédure
qui est tout à fait valable dans les
termes d'une ing mais lourde mais qu'il
est long qui est complexe ou qui est
extrêmement arbitraire car vous aurez
des comités qui vont effectivement
accepté ces femmes et d'autres ne vont
pas les accepter sur quels critères
allez vous les acceptez souvent ses
patientes là parce que moi aussi je j'ai
procédé ainsi
on les passe en psychiatrie mais en fait
elles n'ont pas de pathologie
psychiatrique
c'est une histoire sociale c'est une
histoire psychologique s'est pas
automatiquement une pathologie
psychiatrique alors le dernier élément
auquel je voudrais une panda israël
c'est l'histoire des complications dans
l'état sanitaire dans lequel nous sommes
c'est à dire de bonnes conditions
sanitaires légers est fait dans de
bonnes conditions avec des risques de
complications minimes risque zéro ça
n'existe pas en médecine nous le savons
tous
mais je voudrais quand même dire une
autre chose par rapport à la technique
c'est que au fond les services de
gynéco-obstétrique font depuis très
longtemps des interruptions de grossesse
tardives dans le cadre des jmj
donc ils s'affairent
y'a pas après on peut former plus de
gens en particulier dans les centres
d'orthogénie mais gynécologue
obstétricien ils ont l'habitude des
interruptions de grossesse tardives pour
des raisons médicales professeur nisand
je sais que vous voulez réagir je vous
laisserai à g et j'aborderai une autre
notion juste après contrairement à ce
que vient de tir macaulay que daniel
hassoun jmg règle la totalité des
problèmes parce que vous le savez lee mg
n'est pas limité en délais nous avons la
possibilité de faire une img à 18
semaines et ça nous est arrivé à 20
semaines et ça nous est arrivé
et comme elle vient de le dire nous
savons faire et je pense qu'il ne faut
pas envoyer ces femmes à l'étranger
si on passe par l'allongement du délai
qui est demandé eh bien on dire on
revient sur le même sujet dans trois ans
pour aller à 18 semaines et on revient
dans le même sujet et trois ans plus
tard pour aller à 20 semaines
je propose qu'on mette fin à ce débat et
qu'on dise liège et psychosociale et
bien il ya une commission qui est faite
de médecins c'est les mêmes médecins que
ce qu'ils font actuellement qui ne fait
pas une procédure lourde qui fait une
procédure extrêmement rapide et on peut
mesurer la rapidité de cette procédure
mais si une procédure qui encadrent qui
elle parce que c'est un signe d'appel
une femme qui vient tardivement pour son
ivg je vous rappelle que c'est moins de
2% des femmes
c'est à dire pas 5000 pas 3000 pas 2000
mais beaucoup moins et personne ne la
manche près personne de la mesurer
correctement ce que je dis c'est que
nous en prenant les femmes en urgence
depuis 30 ans à strasbourg c'est à dire
le jour où l appel
elles ont un rendez vous nous n'avons
que dix demandes de dépassement de télé
par an et c'est tout déni de grossesse
et des petites jeunes
prenons-les en charge beaucoup mieux que
par la simple léger c'est-à-dire en les
aidant avec une psychologue avec une
assistance sociale c'est à dire par la
qualité des soins
c'est sûr que s'il pas aussi élégant que
d'allonger le délai parce que ça si très
payant sur le plan électoral mais c'est
pas payant pour les femmes alors
je vous laisse répondre et après je me
permets de reprendre un tout petit peu
la main à les m'a d'abord je crois qu'on
est pas obligé d'être insultant dans ce
débat et de soupçonner quelqu'un comme
moi de porter ce dossier pour des
raisons électorales on peut considérer
qu'on a des convictions qui sont
différentes c'est ce que je pense de
vous monsieur nisand et les miennes sont
aussi respectable que les vôtres ça
c'est la première remarque
la deuxième remarque c'est de dire que
la procédure 10 mg c'est une procédure
dans laquelle la femme demande un
collège de médecins de prendre une
décision la concernant
c'est à dire que le transilien transfert
de la décision la femme perd son droit à
liv et j'ai pour se remettre un collège
et puis enfin ne parlons pas comme si
cette histoire de 16 semaines d'abord
cette semaine cette année puis 18 puis
vint tout ceci n'est tout ceci n'est pas
sérieux je trouve comme argumente ne
parlons pas comme si on inventait
quelque chose qui n'existe pas nos
voisins espagnols hollandais ou
britanniques ne sont pas des barbares et
par ailleurs je crois ce qu'on a tous
loués et on s'est réjoui de ce qui s'est
passé en argentine
il y a quelques semaines les femmes
enfin obtenu la loi et vous savez quel
est le délai qu'a été retenu en
argentine
celui que nous proposons de prendre pour
la france demain c'est à dire celui de
14 cm semaines dont quatre semaines
n'est pas un délai qui est anormal dans
l'histoire d'oliver juge la planète
faisons cette comparaison dans le
rapport d'information sur l'hiver
jolivet j'ai rendu public en septembre
dernier par l'assemblée on a apprit
alors ce chiffre là peut-être que vous
le contesterait que près de cent mille
personnes
allez à l'étranger 5000 femmes à aller à
l'étranger pour se faire avorter
hors délais légaux où vont-elles on va
regarder ce tableau des pays qui vont
parfois bien au-delà des 12 semaines
l'espagne et l'autriche autorisent
l'avortement jusqu'à 14 semaines la
suède jusqu'à la 18e semaine de
grossesse les pays bas jusqu'à la 22e
semaine le royaume uni 24 semaines au
canada il n'ya carrément pas de délai
légal
aucun délai maximal pour se faire
avorter on fit confiance aux femmes
c'est ce que nous a dit professeur yves
ville chef du service d'obstétrique de
l'hôpital necker à paris on l'écouté
évidemment je vous fait réagir après
savais qu'au canada qui est un pays que
tout un chacun et en particulier
francophones considèrent
civilisé eh bien il n'y a pas de terre
mal ivg et on fait simplement confiance
aux femmes donc des gynécologues
renommée prennent des femmes pour être
des idiotes qui oublieraient simplement
leur pilule ou kiêu dans la pilule
aurait été un échec et qui ont besoin
très très vite d'une ivg est très très
vite et bien ceci est assez dégradant
pour l'image de la femme corinna bien je
trouve que ça pose une question très
intéressante et je vous ferai réagir
évidemment mais est ce qu'on ne doit pas
tout simplement faire confiance aux
femmes
bien sûr qu'il faut faire confiance aux
femmes évidemment ça serait mal venu de
dire le contraire mais pour autant pour
autant que je suis pas sûr et je partage
les propos du professeur nisand
je suis pas sûr que de repousser de deux
mois le délai pour une ivg réglera le
problème parce qu'effectivement je pense
que d'ici quelques temps on continuera
les comparaisons je précise encore il
n'aperçoit de deux mois excusez moi
notez la date limite pour une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
remettrait le débat dans quelques temps
bien sûr qu'il faut faire confiance aux
femmes bien sûr qu'il ya des femmes qui
il ya yahoud à des micro c'est sous un
problème de pilules et c'est ce que
décrivait au début de votre émission
ma collègue mais pour autant est ce que
la loi doit s'écrire pour pallier
quelque à quelques exceptions je n'en
suis pas sûr le chiffre de 5000
personnes 5000 fans qui rêvent étrangers
il n'est pas il n'est pas prouvé j'avais
plutôt un chiffre entre 1500 et 2000
situation de famille sera obligé d'aller
à l'étranger pour pratiquer une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
donc encore il faut il faut re
il faut que le débat soit apaisée moi je
suis pas convaincu du tout que
l'allongement de deux semaines règle le
problème pour toutes ces femmes même si
on les fait grandement leur on leur
donne évidemment plein écouter pleine
confiance et c'est ça qui est important
mais c'est ça peut pas être à la carte
israël nisand sur cette question de la
confiance aux femmes est ce que je peux
juste vous rappeler les mots très forts
du discours de simone veil en 74 devant
l'assemblée nationale
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes c'est toujours indre
m et cela restera toujours un drame
aucune femmes n'avortent par plaisir ou
par confort israël nisand
est-ce qu'on peut pas leur faire
confiance c'est ce que je fais depuis
que je suis dans cette discipline et je
me suis battu souvent contre ma
discipline pour que les femmes et c'est
pour ça que j'avais remis un rapport en
1999 à martine aubry pour que les femmes
en besoin d' ivg d'un parcours que
sainte j'avais été à l'origine de
l'allongement du délai et je n'avais pas
anticipé le retrait d'un certain nombre
de collègues je voudrais répondre à
laurence rossignol
la participation des médecins la
décision est-ce que c'est tellement
désagréable que ça
somme toute ce sont les médecins qui
vont faire ces gestes-là alors participé
à la décision
c'est à dire obtenir leur agrément c'est
à dire demander au médecin qui va faire
est ce que est ce que tu es d'accord de
le faire est ce que vous imaginez
d'ailleurs laurence rossignol
un autre système que le système de gré à
gré qui consiste à dire voilà un geste
qui va être un peu plus difficile un peu
plus longue ou qui survient c'est une
femme qui a besoin d'une aide
différentes
mettons en place des moyens autour de
cette femme pour que l'aide soit
beaucoup plus cossus et que nous
puissions la compagnie est-ce que c'est
tellement injurieux que de dire il faut
respecter totalement le droit des femmes
et je suis le premier à le dire mais il
faut aussi que les médecins soient
d'accord d'effectuer ses gestes eh bien
je pense que c'est normal et naturel et
on ne peut pas parler de bientraitance
des femmes sans évoquer le problème de
la compétence et de l'acceptation par
les médecins de ces gestes alors deux
choses je reviens sur la confiance je
reviens sur la confiance
c'est ainsi qu un débat qu'on a eu en
2001 au moment du passage de 10 à 12
semaines
c'est à dire dire que les femmes sont au
fond d idiote et que parce qu'elles ont
un temps plus long
elles vont retarder leur ivg etc c'est
une aberration qui ne s'est pas
confirmée par les chiffres
les femmes avant de plus en plus tôt ce
qui veut bien dire que celle qui arrive
à des termes au delà de ce qui est légal
sont des femmes qui sont dans des
difficultés majeures et qu'on peut pas
même si c'est un petit nombre
comme ça les négligés et dire est ce
nécessaire de faire une loi pour un
petit nombre
oui ça peut l'être parce que ça ce sont
des femmes qui sont les plus en
difficulté pour répondre il sera aidé
dix ans par rapport aux médecins je
dirais et là je suis en total désaccord
avec lui
non ce n'est pas au médecin que je suis
moi gynécologue obstétricienne ayant
fait des ivg toute ma vie ce n'est pas à
moi de décider si une femme peu ou pas
garder sa grossesse mon travail de
médecin ces deux c'est d'abord de faire
les choses le mieux possible
techniquement de ne pas la mettre en
danger et 2 et 2 effectivement nous voir
s'il n'y a pas de contre indications ça
c'est mon rôle de médecin
ce n'est pas mon rôle de médecin je
parle de médecins et non pas seulement
deux femmes se trouve que je suis femme
est médecin
ce n'est pas mon rôle de médecin de dire
oui non pour cette raison j'accompagne
jeu j'écoute j'entends et je fais ce
qu'on me demande de faire car c'est dans
la loi
laurence rossignol sur la question de la
conscience aux femmes parlant d'y
revenir
mais il ya ces questions qui reviennent
régulièrement est-ce que l'avortement
est un peu banalisé dédramatiser avec
les années c'est l'avis de la philosophe
chantal delsol qui s'était exprimé dans
une tribune au figaro vox en 2017 je
vois sourire mais son avis peut aussi
être intéressant dans ce débat simone
veil ce que fut son intention en 75 et
ce qu'est devenue sa loi depuis voilà le
titre de cette tribune et voilà ce
qu'elle écrivait
le fait que les ivg soit devenu un droit
une option comme une autre comme on le
voit dans le feuilleton plus belle la
vie
larhant banal et par là insignifiante ce
qu à aucun moment simone veil n'avait
voulu qu'en pensez vous mais je pense
que la question de diverger n'est pas
consensuelle en france ce qui s'est
passé au moment de la loi veil avec une
très forte hostilité de la droite à
l'assemblée nationale la veille qu'on
devrait d'ailleurs d'ailleurs appelée
loi halimi veille je pense que gisèle
halimi est pour beaucoup dans les de
l'adoption de cette loi ce qui s'est
passé avec une très forte opposition de
la droite à l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas totalement disparu
nous avons toujours en france des
adversaires actifs de nive et j'ai des
gens qui considèrent que lille vg est un
meurtre que la pilule du lendemain est
un avortement
ça existe aussi et vous prenez des
manuels qui sont diffusées par la
fondation lejeune à destination des
jeunes lycéens que leurs acquis leurs
parents en confiance et ses livres vous
y trouvez en tout cas réquisitoire
contre les vg et contre la pilule du
lendemain
on entend de penser que ça a été un peu
banal il alors où ce que je pense c'est
que l'opinion est totalement favorable à
ce nouveau droit des femmes qu'il y en
ait plus nouveau quant à l'histoire que
le gg ont été banalisés ça veut dire que
pour les femmes
les vg serait une alternance une autre
contraception ceci est faux alors moi je
pense pas tout à fait comme le disait
simone veil que ni vg soit
systématiquement un drame pour les
femmes
certaines femmes vie bleury et bg avec
en serre en serrant les dents c'est pas
un moment agréable pour toute femme n'y
a pas d'assignation au traumatisme
contrairement à ce qu'on nous raconte
mais surtout il ya un enjeu idéologique
c'est une liberté c'est un droit des
femmes
regardez ce qui se passe en pologne
regardons ce qui s'est passé en
argentine
ces femmes ont conquis le droit à
disposer de leur corps contre anf
l'église catholique en porc en argentine
et elles l'ont perdue en pologne ce
droit sous la pression d'un gouvernement
particulièrement conservateur donc
cessons de discuter comme si on était
tous d'accord
est ce que j'observe c'est que les
adversaires de livres et j'ai
aujourd'hui ont compris une chose c'est
qu'on peut pas demander là
rogations de la loi veil ils peuvent pas
le demander parce que l'opinion est à 4
plus de 80% soutient cette loi donc ce
qu'ils font c'est que dont ils disent on
s'en tient à la loi veil en ignorant qu
entre la loi veil et maintenant l'état
de l'opinion et du débat a changé et
donc c'est un simple reconnaît les
adversaires de nive et j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'ils disent la loi vers un
cloud réveil et bien nous avons
progressé au début il y avait quand même
l'exigence dans la loi veil d'une
condition de détresse nous l'avons
supprimer progressivement israël nisand
effectivement évoqué son rapport nous
avons allongé le délai nous avons
supprimé le délai de réflexion
il y avait dans la loi avait un délai de
réflexion c'est ça qui est intéressant
sur les questions de la confiance
en fait les femmes il fallait qu'elle
réfléchisse bien elle venait à l'hôpital
de mende et une ivg et on leur disait
romney dans huit jours réfléchit c'est
bien parce que probablement vous êtes
venus là comme ça sur un coup de tête
comme si une femme venait sur un coup de
tête demandé une ivg
alors tout ça est un est une affaire
idéologique culturelle et politique
ce texte sera rejeté au sénat demain
cela fait pas de doute il va repartir à
l'assemblée nationale qui pourrait
décider de le reprogrammer en mars du
côté de l'exécutif on est assez frileux
en pleine crise sanitaire le
gouvernement a préféré émettre un avis
de sagesse olivier ferrand l'a exprimé
en octobre devant les parlementaires et
la complexité de sa phrase en dit long
sur son embarras écouter ça dure
quelques secondes regard de l'attention
que je porte et que j'ai toujours porté
l exercice de ce droit fondamental
une barbe ne m'apparaît donc pas
aujourd'hui possible de considérer que
l'orientation principale de ce texte
résoudra en tout cas à lui seul l'accès
à l'ivg et g c'est donc avec une sagesse
hautement mesurées sur des raisons
formelles mais qui sont significatives
auxquelles je crois que le gouvernement
abordera chacune des questions soulevées
par les articles et les amendements
bon voilà corinne imbert est ce que
c'est pour ça qu'ils font les femmes
dommage pour les femmes et ça me corinne
imbert vous pensez qu effectivement
l'exécutif boîte un peu en touche sous
la pression de ses anti ivg dont parle
et laurence rossignol
oui certainement il est certainement un
manque de courage du ministre mais je
voudrais justement dire gentiment que
l'église se signale que la droite
républicaine se résume pas la fondation
lejeune
je suis de droite et au groupe est
républicain
j'y suis opposé chez sandoz et la voix
sur la loi bioéthique
ce n'est pas la fondation lejeune
corinne imbert je vous rend cet hommage
sur quoi je lui dis merci l'euro c'est
ainsi écoutez je suis désolé je disais
en coûtera droite se résumer passage
opposé à a dirigé comme un certain
nombre de mes collègues mais je ne pense
pas très sincèrement que des rochers de
semaine ne réglera le problème quand on
est ministre on voit bien qu'il est très
très prudent parce qu'effectivement il a
la pression peut-être de l'opinion mais
encore une fois c'est la décision d'une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
prise par une femme j'ai peut-être dire
une évidence mais suffisamment
douloureux c'est un choix difficile et
que déjà ça ça mérite le respect donc
voilà pas s'en aller plus loin je pense
que c'est déjà une chose pour notre pays
que cette cette interruption volontaire
de grossesse soit possible soit possible
depuis plus de 40 ans en france et qu'on
n'a pas attendu les années 2020 pour
évidemment l'autoriserait nylon on voit
bien que les vg pose encore quelques
questions certains effectivement
continue de remettre en question va voir
quelques images puisque c'est le cas de
militants qui ont manifesté le week-end
dernier place du trocadéro à paris selon
les sources ils étaient entre 1000 et
5000 personnes aidant ça change un peu
la donne pour sécuriser ce droit le
professeur yves ville de necker propose
de l'introduire dans la constitution
c'était à lire dans le parisien hier
vous avez dû lire ça aussi israël nisand
est ce qu'il faudrait inscrire ce droit
dans la constitution pour définitivement
verrouillé ce droit je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse revenir en arrière sur le
droit à l'image est dans notre pays 95%
des personnes sont satisfaites que ce
droit ils systéme m
les gens qui ont défilé lorsqu'ils ont
leur fille de 13 ans qui se trouve
enceinte qui viennent en consultation
ils disent vous savez je suis contre
lille et j'aimais quand même pour ma
fille tout de même donc le droit les vg
je ne le sens pas menacé je vais vous
dire ce qui est menacé c'est l'émoi
bien dont nous disposons pour accueillir
les femmes
nous n'avons pas de moyens et s'exonérer
à bas prix en faisant une loi qui soit
disant améliore l'accès libye j'ai alors
ça n'améliore en rien du tout et que ça
fragilise ce droit ça me fâche nous
n'avons pas les moyens d'accueillir les
femmes dans des centres d'orthogénie
heureusement qu'il ya le monde libéral
qui fait 30 % des ivg dans les cabinets
pour les ivg traita très précoce mais
pour les soixante dix au total qui vont
dans les hôpitaux on se trouvent dans
des situations à certains endroits les
chefs de service ont maintenu les moyens
contre vents et marées mais si au
détriment d'autres activités je dis la
chose suivante si on veut vraiment aider
les femmes en demande ivg c'est pas en
allongeant le délai qu on le fait parce
que ça on peut régler le problème des
délais dépassés très facilement dans
notre pays
ce n'est pas en disant aux médecins de
travail et chanter si je te laisserai
pas dire ça y est ça l on ne peut pas
régler le problème des délais tardif
facilement on les règle peut-être dans
ton service ce n'est pas le cas ailleurs
dans d'autres régions de france où c'est
une galère pas possible pour les femmes
et je rappelle qu'en ce moment période
de pandémie il ya un petit problème
aussi pour se rendre à l'étranger
j'ai eu avant-hier un coup de téléphone
d'une jeune femme qui est à 16 ce même
qui doit partir hollande et c'est pas
simple en ce moment un gardien n'avait
pas d'amis
merci merci infiniment à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat lpl continue place
à notre match daisy